- LOL, excuse me, my
voice just cracked, lol.
- He's screaming.
- [Steven] Excuse me.
- You know, there's two kinds
of people in this world.
... Or....
It's debatable.
(epic music)
- My name is Keith, haha.
- I'm Steven, lol.
- I am team haha because I'm not a liar.
- I'm Kelsey and I lol.
- I'm on team haha, cause
lol is for children.
- And I laugh out loud.
(epic music)
- Lol is the coolest, hippest form
of communication there is on the internet.
- Vic, you're a cool guy.
- (laughs) What can I say?
- [Kelsey] Let's talk about OG.
Lol was the OG of laughing language.
And I still use it, and
I'm not ashamed to say.
I think I'm still pretty cool.
Would you say so?
- I think you're deec.
- Haha is a form of speaking
for older generation people.
How old are you, Keith?
- I am 28, Steven.
- What! 28?
- We are now in this new frontier
where we are exploring a whole
new way of communicating.
- Or we are getting lazier
about the way we communicate,
therefore distancing
ourselves from each other.
- Now you just sound like an old man.
- What? (laughing)
Says the old man!
- [Steven] You were around
before computers existed.
You were around when
the dinosaurs were here.
- This is like arguing
with a kindergartner.
- Kindergartners are hip.
- There is one thing that
clinches lol over hahaha,
which is that one handed action
is capable on the keyboard.
- L and O are right next to
each other on the keyboard.
With haha...
- It's one more letter!
- Shut your mouth, Zach!
- I believe that we should be adding
new words to our vocabulary.
- It's not a new word, it's an acronym.
It's not adding a new
word to our vocabulary.
- Sure it is, we've been
doing this for generations.
Radar is a word.
- OK, well, it is a word.
- It has also inspired many variations.
- With haha you just have
haha and hehe and that's it.
- When you want to emphasize
something you say, "LOL."
- That's not a variation,
that's two words.
- You can lollllll.
You can lmbo.
You can lololol.
- Lolololol (coughs)
(epic music)
- Haha is the perfect thing to text.
- Haha is so versatile.
- You can say "haha,"
you can just say "ha."
- You can type "hahaha."
You could be really amused by this.
You could be "ha space ha"
and that's a sarcastic laugh.
- Also, haha, if you're like
a sword dual with someone,
you go "haha," it means
you have the upper hand.
- Yeah, you sound snooty as fuck.
- You would say things like haha
which is older than lol, it's too old.
The original is the beginning, Steven!
- The beginning of
technology, the new age,
and you are, my friend,
a man of the dinosaurs.
- Haha has been around since forever.
Forever beats 1998 over here, every time.
Ten times out of ten.
- Lol is, you're right,
it is of technology,
and it only belongs there,
whereas haha can exist
in text and in life.
- This is haha. (laughs)
That's how you spell it.
- That sounded like
"ungh." (choking sound)
- Haha can be translated to any language
based on the way it sounds
when people from those cultures laugh.
Lol only works for English speakers.
In Spanish it's "jaja"
which is very close.
- Lol is used to diffuse
awkward situations.
- Hey, you trying to grab
some drinks tonight, lol?
What is funny, why is that, that's not...?
I'm not laughing out loud
when I'm saying that.
- Hey, do you mind doing
the dishes later, lol?
What's funny about doing the dishes?
- That just means your roommate sucks.
- If anything lol, yes,
is an iteration of haha,
because it saying "ha" out loud.
- Hey, hey!
Don't hover over.
See, you're pretentious,
you're like "hahaha!"
- Text is meant to be
on top of one another.
That's what they do.
- No.
- They literally appear like
this, this is what they do.
They trade spaces, that's
how text works, Steven.
(epic music)
- Haha is what's appropriate.
Lol is too aggressive,
no one actually means it,
and haha is just like,
"haha, you tried, good job."
- Lol is universal, it can
apply to any situation, really.
- Listen, I just think lol
is for fucking children,
and I only want to talk to adults.
- We can agree on one thing.
Anybody who says "lol"out loud,
they are fucking demons.
- Psychopaths.
- Yeah, no way.
- You're old, I'm cool.
Go kindergartners, we're done, we out.
- He said it best.
- The face of defeat.
(epic music)
- As long as you've written
down what he said...
- [Steven] Nothing to say!
(grunting)
- [Keith] This man...
This man is a train wreck.